appearing out of nowhere on monday an
item by tom brady well with tom
brighty's name on it at the
playerstribune.com one of the criticisms
of that website is the items really
aren't written by the players they're
written by staff and sure it's the
players ideas and concepts there's a lot
of ghost writing that many believe goes
on there so it's not like tom brady sat
down at a laptop and banged out this
2600 word column now i sat down and read
the thing chris and there really wasn't
anything in there that made me say wow
that's insightful wow that's something i
didn't know the biggest revelation was
when he was drafted by the patriots in
2000 he didn't even know where new
england was he wondered whether or not
it was even an actual place like where
do you find new england on a map so that
part of it was kind of funny but you
know ultimately ultimately the thing
that was most glaring to me and and i
want to be fair with tom brady here but
man to have
to have
i'm choosing my words carefully
i
to have 2 600 words
now
in today's climate with everything
that's going on where he talks about his
transition from the team he's been with
for 20 years and his preparations to hit
the ground sprinting with the tampa bay
buccaneers
to have no mention whatsoever of the
pandemic how the pandemic's going to
affect his preparations how the pandemic
currently is impacting his life it's
like it's not even happening
and i don't know whether he's just like
mentally ignoring it or he's so caught
up in his own life it's not even a
factor or if he thinks that he's lived
this charmed life that would never be
touched by the coronavirus in any way
shape or form
i just thought it was bizarre given the
obvious overlap between the pandemic and
his ability or inability to prepare for
the season his first season with a new
team of his entire career
how does that not come up in a 2600 word
column
well listen i i understand what you're
saying i mean you would think there
would be some reference to what is going
on in the world today and yes how your
life you know trying to be a new tampa
bay buccaneer might be changed by the
challenges you know
uh posed by covid19 but you know this is
within line of what brady does he just
keeps it professional and stays on topic
to football you know one thing you know
if i was going to complain a little bit
about tom brady off the field yeah i
wish he would take a stands on certain
issues and things and be a little bit
more vocal but he has not never been
that way you know even with the cba
contracts this one and the last one i
mean he was by far the most popular
person in football for this one and last
one and nothing is said there to you
know make a statement to get you know
the players behind him and and show a
little leadership that way you know i
just think he's very cognizant almost
like a michael jordan where you know
they just never want to make any
statement that they feel like
ruffle any group or entities feathers at
all and i think that's you know part of
the corporation of tb12
but we do we do have to be fair here
the antitrust lawsuit that was filed by
the players against the league after the
lockout in 2011 was called brady versus
the nfl he was one of the named
plaintiffs
but still but still chris i'm just
saying we can't say that he's stayed out
of these issues completely but mike
nobody even knows that until you just
said that nobody knows that and i didn't
even know it until you reminded me in
commercial break so you know it would
have been more effective is he got in
front of a microphone and put his face
to it and then said some things like
that but yes they used him as a name on
that to do that you're right and i'll
give him credit for that you're right
i'm not trying to be a total jerk here
i'm just trying to point out that he's
been reluctant to put his face and name
and out there that way with anything
controversial and i think that's
probably why he's trying to stay away
from this right now even though i don't
know what would be controversial about
covet 19 right now other than we have
some people that are just reluctant to
accept the reality that we're in well
i i look at it this way
there's already a wall between him and
the average person i mean it's a
gigantic wall it's a huge wall right
it's bigger than the wall that jim irsay
built in indianapolis with his offensive
line he's going to build a wall right
and and this is an opportunity for him
to come off as a human being to show
that this
like like it's it he comes off in this
thing as not even the coronavirus can
shatter my bubble can even puncture my
bubble i have this charmed life that is
separate apart from anything anyone else
has to deal with i don't get it he
writes it maybe or some someone writes
it may be the off season now but to me
it feels like the season has already
started that comes off as so freaking
out of touch chris when we're dealing
with daily questions of whether or not
the draft is going to go forward
off-season programs what's the season
going to look like are they going to
have a season will there be stands for
him to say it may be the offseason but
to me it feels like the season's already
started my reaction is what the hell
planet are you on tom because it surely
isn't earth
well yeah well this is why he's tom
brady and you and me are sitting here
talking into a camera because you know
in his mind he's waking up going it's
the 2020 season you know he's a psycho
tom first time are you willing to give
it all up for to win because he was
right i mean i believe him i know it
i've seen it he is yes i think he's
focused on that so i think it's a little
bit of what makes him great too so we
can't lose that aspect of that that i
mean that that is how he's wired he's
ultra focused on what he needs to do and
i think he's very good at blocking out
the outside world that's also which
makes him great what i'm like intrigued
by mike i mean
what what happened did like did derek
jeter like go okay i'll sell you the
house and i'll take away 50 000 a month
in rent but you have to do a player's
tribute or somebody from the player's
tribute i don't understand how that i
think he sold it but i think i think
peter is sold sold totally out of it
okay
i don't know anything about the details
there there was an item in november that
minute media was buying the players
tribune because frankly i mean look peop
fans understand that you're really not
getting what you think you're getting i
don't want to i don't want to diss the
players tribune but uh
as previously mentioned it's really not
the kind of access and insight that uh
that that they sold it as and as
evidenced by a 2600 word column from tom
brady that really doesn't see anything
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports